also mein vortrag handelt vom thema
jenseits von fatalismus und indifferent
ismus johann heinrich friedrich karl
vorberg über findige selbstbestimmung
diese denker sind im einen oder anderen
bekannt die meisten ziemlich kennen
was hat es damit auf sich johann
heinrich hat einen kleinen aufsatz
geschrieben über die freiheit des
willens und für diesen text der stehen
zwei mal eben in lateinischer schrift in
dieser materialien sammlung materialien
zu kants kritik der praktischen vernunft
aber auch der ist zeigen nicht mehr so
gut verfügbar
und der wird auch teil dieser edition
sein von denen ich gesprochen habe und
in diesem text der nicht so lange ist
unternehmer ist eine ganz ganz
interessante strategien möchte nämlich
gegen die freiheitskriege oder
fatalisten kurz für die realität der
freiheit argumentieren er schreibt ich
will meinen glauben an freiheit
beibehalten gebe ich meine mutter natur
gelehrt hat vielleicht eher die treue
mich wahrheit gelehrt lasst sie uns
darum fragen und unseren glauben
überzeugung zu verwandeln suchen ist auf
jeden fall freiheit geführt wurde
angesichts der damaligen debatte um die
freiheit des willens und wie viele eben
auch nachgeben versteht sich als ein
cantiamo aber nicht nur als ein
dogmatisches kann diana der jetzt alles
übernehmen sondern er bewahrt seine
eigenständigkeit und das lässt ihn auch
schon in diese kontinuität stellen von
fichte von kelly und edel würde ich
behaupten er sagt nämlich dann wird am
schluss seines textes leicht wahrnehmen
dass diese darstellung der lehre von der
freiheit nichts anderes ist als eine
etwas veränderte erörterung der
kantischen leere
neben diesen gegenstand die
transzendentale kausalität bleibt die
nämliche oder wege auf der er sicheres
dasein für
soll womöglich endlicher vorgezeigt
werden mich hat dieses zitat gleich
erinnert
schelling der nämlich schrieben die
philosophie ist noch nicht am ende
kannte der tat gegeben die prämisse
fehlen noch
also das ergebnis ist wir sind frei aber
wie wir genau dazu jetzt kommen genau
diese freiheit zu verstehen also diese
prämissen die müssen noch etwas genauer
dargelegt wird und so sehe ich auch alle
bemühungen die prämissen der gallischen
ergebnisse dass wir drei sind jedoch
genauer zu rekonstruieren
er hatte mich sehr an diesen brief an
schnellinger nägel natürlich sechs jahre
später erinnert jetzt gibt es
systematischen problemstellungen bei
abrüstung deswegen finde ich auch seine
texte interessant er sage der begriff
der freiheit ist mit indifferenz oder
inter termin ist muss unvereinbar wenn
er nicht mit indifferenz vereinbar ist
wie kann dann die determination des
willens zugedacht werden dass er dadurch
gerade frei ist das scheint sicher
ersten auszuschließen
ein wille darf doch irgendwie gar nicht
bestimmt zahl um häuser zu können wäre
ja determiniert jetzt kann man sich
natürlich genauer fragen wie sie diese
termination aus und arabisch
argumentiert für ein begriff der
freiheit als das zitat das vermögen der
alleinige selbst und sei als polens zu
sein
dazu soll sich fragen wie diese selbst
grundes wollen es genau zu verstehen ist
wie es dir genau zu verstehen wie kann
der selbstkontrolle platziert werden
also habe ich versucht nicht nur
technologisch oder begrifflich den
selbst grund des willens zu bestimmen
sondern möchte ihnen auch im kantischen
rahmen zu einer total für die so viel
reduzieren wie ich glaube er spricht von
beweisen aber man kann sehen dass diese
reduktion der unternehmen ziemlich an
halo ist oder sogar komplementär ist
zudem was kann eben mit dem mit der
trans zentralen reduktionen der
verstandes begriffe gemacht hat dass
wälder nicht nur
sehr originelle weise an das sind diese
fragestellung habe ich nimmt nun einen
möglichen einwand gegen die auffassung
von freiheit als selbst grund des
wollens auf der die position des
intellekts fatalismus von schmid
christian schmidt erinnern
das ist jetzt so ein einwand den er sich
macht also der grund welcher nötig wenn
freiheit nicht indifferenz sein darauf
die freiheits moralische oder innere
notwendigkeit interessant sein wenn sie
das ist so ist es gleich viel
als ob man ihn drin oder äußere
notwendigkeit an
das ist so der punkt den beiden fällen
geht der begriff der freiheit verlor und
das wäre jetzt ein einwand dass man sagt
freiheit hat auch mit der tradition mit
nötigung mit bestimmtheit gar nichts zu
tun
dann sind wir gerade auch wieder unfrei
und darauf antwortet jetzt dem licht auf
diesen ein mann den er sich selbst macht
freiheit bedeutet keine innere nötigung
oder einschränkungen
diese innere nötigung sondern vielmehr
ist es die realität der freiheit
mitnichten sagte es liegt nur ein
missverständnis der freuen bei innerer
notwendigkeit ein leiden wie bei der
äußeren notwendigkeit und das solltest
du nicht trend ist insgeheim das prinzip
der tätigkeit und des wollens von dem
prinzip wie es nötig und das ist wieder
nicht wohl getan denn als dann findest
du allerdings ein tätiges und ein leiden
das etwas das leidende ist sind ein
gedanke wille und diese das eigentlich
ich das nötige hat keine bestimmte
stelle der substanz und nun fällt auch
freilich zugleich alle unterschied
zwischen äußeren innerer notwendigkeit
über den haufen
also das darf eben nicht gedacht werden
freiheit ist auch wenn sie eine gewisse
nötigung beinhaltet nicht unmöglich
sagen sie setzt das voraus freiheit als
selbst rund des wollens ist deswegen wie
habe ich zahle identisch mit innerer
notwendigkeit die kann man jetzt auch
schon an harry frankfurt denken dem ich
jetzt nicht eigens einbeziehen möchte er
auch von einer bullischen spd spricht
als auch in der gegenwärtigen debatte
freiheit häufig als eine besondere form
von bestimmtheit gedacht und sagte zu
dieser innere notwendigkeit dass ich
will notwendig weil es selbst will es
verhält sich also nicht leiden bei
dieser selbst nötigung oder besser
selbstbestimmung denn die innere
notwendigkeit heißt das stimmte besen
das ding ist eine ansicht bestimmte
tätigkeit selbst insofern wir uns arbeit
in zuschauer das selbsttätige ding
vorstellen und aus dem grund seines
handelns angeben worden
so bleiben wir bei dem dinge als grunde
stehen und den es einmal als grund ein
andermal und zwar zugleich darauf als
durch den grund benötige
und jetzt wird es lebend in der zweiten
vorstellung ist also bloß täuschende
vorstellung wenn wir an ein bleiben bei
ihrer tätigkeit in einer notwendigkeit
den kann als innere notwendigkeit darf
nicht analog gesehen werden
die äußere notwendigkeit innere
notwendigkeit hat ein vorzug dieser
gegenüber jetzt kann man sich weiter
fragen worin genau der selbst grund es
wurden gestellt worin genau das sagt
kantischen rahmen sein transzendentale
astrid besteht aber es geht jetzt
folgendermaßen vor
er nimmt phänologische die erscheinung
des wollens war er betrachtet die und
dazu gehören zum beispiel ein und
regierte zustimmung erzählt noch weitere
erscheinung des wollens auftrieb irisch
gegeben sind und schließt dann oder
genau das depot ziehen dank auf die
diesen erscheinung notwendigerweise zu
grunde liegenden inneren substanziellen
gründe so nennt die substanzielle gründe
und die inneren gründe des wollen stehen
eine analogie äußeren substanziellen
kunden der erscheinungen
also habe ich mache das ganze zu
erkenntnistheorie wir haben erscheinen
und den müssen während das wechsel
gründe zu grunde liegen
wieder vor dem sie stammen und genau so
muss es auch sein wenn wir unsere
inneren erscheinen betrachten auch den
müssen gründe zu grunde leben und hier
sieht man schon wie ich meine dass er
kann's system vervollständigen möchte
oder komplementieren möchte kann hatte
sich ja recht ausgeschrieben was diese
inneren gründe anbelangen haid gleich zu
beginn der kritik der reinen vernunft
schreibt auf was uns selbst anbelangt zu
schweigen wir glauben zitat von bacon
also da möchten arbeiten organisieren
mehr machen wenn es um die inneren
erscheinung geht und ihre gründe
gefragt was für substanzielle trans
zentrale letzte gründe werden wir ihnen
den erscheinungen des willens nun
unterlegen müssen irre lustig zugehörige
oder äußere müssen wir auf internet
austragen so ist dass ich als der
inbegriff aller inneren substantiell
begründet er alleiniges selbstkontrollen
der wille ist frei im transalpinen mit
ihnen besetzten falle aber nicht also
hier sieht man schon dass ich wird eine
große rolle spielen ganz analog wie das
transaktion der rhein verstandes
begriffe und jetzt unterscheidet aber
auch zwei momente des bundes des wollens
einmal den richtungs grund so nennt er
eben ich würde jetzt sagen der
theologische aspekt also wohin ist das
wollen gerichtet oder ist
internationalität jetzt eine
teleologische nasdaq und dann nehmen wir
noch einen zweiten ein zweites moment
dieses selbst bundes dass der sack
treiben oder nötigungs grund ich würde
es diesen motivation alias big
bezeichnen der er diese kraft beinhaltet
und unterscheidet oder 2 grundgesetz der
willenskraft das erste grundgesetz
lautet alle erscheinungen des wollens
steht und empirische vorstellung als
unter bestimmten gründen auf das heben
der zweite grundgesetz lautet alle
erscheinungen des wollens stehe und
empirischen gefühlen als unter
bestimmten gründen das einzige
möglichkeit unsere willens erscheinen
also wir haben wenn wir die
entscheidungen unseres
wielens betrachten ist sowohl mit dem
tierischen vorstellung als auch mit
empirischen gefühlen zu tun diese zwei
arten von thierry macht jetzt habe ich
ihr geld und wenn es um die freiheit des
willens geht um die äußerungen des
selbst rundes und jetzt wird er nicht
etwas was ich die transzendentale
reduktion der freiheit nennen möchte was
kann natürlich so nie gemacht hätte
hätte gesagt hier setzen unsere
verstandes grenzen ein
hier haben wir gar keine erscheinung
richtig und sagte wir haben
erscheinungen wir haben entscheidung des
willens kann sagt der freiheit ist gar
nicht erst richtig in erscheinung tritt
obwohl er immer mal wieder raus wie die
achtung an für die ein vernünftiges
gefühl ist kann and auch phänomene die
natur sind tierische seite haben und auf
freiheit transparenz wie die achtung
aber so nett landeszentrale reduktion
der freiheit kann nicht unternommen
wollen und setzt hier an und wie geht
jetzt vor sich geht erster schritt ist
den empirischen gründen der wilson
entscheidung also nach vorstellung und
gefühle liegen nur in der substanzielle
gründe zugrunde das ist der erste punkt
alles darf nicht dürfen nicht äußere
gründe seien der zweite schritt ist
diese substanzielle gründe also der
vorstellung der gefühle können in einem
einzigen prinzip vereinigt werden
sie haben eine gemeinsame wurzeln und
der dritte schritt der die produktion
lautet dieses einzige band zieht ist das
trans zahle ich als daran an diesem
punkt sind alle gründe des wollens
aufgehängt so wird die kategorien auch
ihren verstandes zu prüfen
zu den ersten punkt sei die option des
richtung des grundes da kann ich
folgendes alle vorstellungen im namen
haben wie sie wollen sind ein leeres
totes etwas welches im bewusstsein
schwebt und schwimmt bevor sie durch den
verstand auch seine manieren sind
geformt und gebildet worden
diese bildung die ganz sein eigenes werk
ist macht die vorstellung der erst jetzt
zu dem was es sind nämlich zustimmte
welche erkenntnisse mit denen jetzt die
seele etwas gewiss und bestimmtes
versichert dann würden wir nun leicht zu
geben dass eine bestimmte richtung der
willenskraft auch durch bestimmte
vorstellung bestehen kann
das ist die rolle des verstandes also
dieses technologisch moment dann sagte
dass dies gelten muss so ist das spiel
von dieser seite schon gewonnen
denn nunmehr davon erwiesen werden dass
alle bestimmungen der vorstellung an
ihre bildungen durch die aufs angewandte
und mit dem vorher noch leere vorstellen
verknüpfte begriffe des verstandes
geschehen da sind die charakteristischen
bestimmungen an ihnen aus machen das
wirklich nur diese uhr begriffe die
bestimmung in richtung der willenskraft
möglich machen für diesen beweisen dass
sich die kante der option diesen
begriffen und dessen kritik des
erkenntnisvermögen sorgen welche beide
feststellen
also den kategorien die kante doziert
hatte ja ein verstandes begriffe die
macht jetzt auch fruchtbar für die
erscheinung des wollens als es wird die
von unserer regionalen strukturen dafür
sind nach ansicht auch die verstandes
begriffe zuständig die kantine für die
erkenntnis der gegenstände der äußeren
gegenstände entdeckt hatte jetzt zur
reduktion des beweggründe
er sagt er vermisste gefühl das sind
bloße innere erscheinungen die also auch
allein in re substanzielle unter
voraussetzt und höchstens besonders
anfangen des lebens äußere dinge nur
abwarten dass sich veranlassen
gelegenheits könnte aber auf keine weise
bestimmen und zu recht zureichende
gründe von ihnen werden
weiteres zitat führt uns als auch diese
empirischen grün der auf einen inneren
substanziellen grundton ob sie gerade
ihnen auf einen transzendentalen selbst
und der willens erscheinung sind so sind
wir auf verzeichnende bewegen könnte
frei und ungebunden veräußere nötigung
so kann kein äußeres die uns an viren
nötigen und bestimmt auch wenn der
innere selbst kommt alle trieb wieder
mit dabei ist wenn er nicht auch von
dieser seite und uns alle die
transzendentale freiheit suchen oder der
substantielleren
empirische nötigungs gründen in
transzendentaler unser erkenntnisstand
übrigens unerreichbar und in der
vordergrund ist also sowohl die gefühle
als auch die vorstellungen als sowohl
der beweggrund als auch der richtungs
grund lassen sich auf diesen auf diese
kategorien zurückführen
beim vertritt die these dass die
angeführten gründe um die
willensentscheidung hervorzubringen
gemeinschaftlich wirken dass die echte
innere richtung sofort auch notwendig
mit einem nötigungs grunde verbunden
zeigt bis jetzt haben wir ja nur die
einrichtungs und bewegungs grunde
separat unterschieden und jetzt geht es
eben darum dass man die einheit dabei
gründe noch aufweist sagt folgendes denn
angenommen dass jeder diese gründe
versicherung von den anderen getrennt
sind
so würde keine anleihen auch nur eine
blind erscheinung erzielen wo sich die
es nicht vermochten zu werden sie
wahrscheinlich in der tat eine gründe
er muss jetzt zeigen wie diese beiden
gründe von vorstellung und von gefühlen
zusammenhängen
ja und das gar nicht überspringen
jetzt geht es um die reduktion dieser
beiden gründe
und jetzt kommt er auf dass ich zu
sprechen auf das trans entsagen nach
dieser kritik von cannes ist also das
verständige nicht der einzige grund
aller vorstellungen sowohl der
vorstellung mit dem das nicht sich
selbst und seine eigenheiten sich
verständlich machen als der bestimmte
begriff von allen bringen dingen und
gegenständen sind aber diese die selbst
eigenheiten stimmen der vorstellung
einzige quelle von unserem interesse und
folglich auf ein nötiges gründen es ist
erwiesen dass die richtungs und nötigung
strände über als samen stimmen verlangt
dass die vorher getreten inneren
substanzielle gründer des empirischen
richtung nötigungs grund ist nur ein
einziger innere substanzieller sie jetzt
prozent eben wie es galt gezeigt hatte
also dass ich das ganze teile ich das
leistet die einheit des richtungslos
bewegungs grund ist
es als erwiesen dass wir uns in dem
substanziellen grunde wenig und sein
inbegriff von vermögen heute unterliegen
auch der transzendentale grund der will
zerspanung liege dass wir freiheit des
willens nennen
wir kennen aber weiter nichts vergeben
als die erscheinungen nämlich die vorher
inneren gefühle als empirische gründe an
vielen erscheinungen von welchen
zusammengenommen der trans en thale oder
substanzielle inneren und ich verletzt
und zu rechnen ist man könnte also sagen
mit kann aber ich hängt alle äußerungen
des wollens am ende an diesem obersten
punkt dem vehikel des transfers auf wie
es kann eben genau mit den kategorien
getan hatte und das ist so diese
leistung von arbeit die ich sehr
interessant finde komplementär auch in
die villen in seiner in seinen häusern
seinen kräften mit den kategorien die
kant aufgezeigt hat zu analysieren und
so die freiheit genauer zu bestimmen und
damit ebenso zeigen dass die
verhandlungen sehr wohl bestimmt sind
eben durch dass ich am ende dann auch
wenn du über das nicht selbst eben nicht
mehr wissen können als diese kategorien
die dann unsere auch richtungs gründe
bestimmen
ein weiterer denker dem ich ganz wichtig
finde in dieser debatte auch viel zu
wenig behandelt wird ist friedrich kauf
fuhrberg der bühne als arbeit und der
hat eine schrift verfasst mit dem titel
über die kunden und gesetze freie
handlungen die 1795 erschienen und die
finde ich es auch wirklich wert mal
behandelt zu werden
das möchte jetzt im schlussteil meines
vortrags tun
[Musik]
vorberg stellt sich jetzt eine andere
situation da hat er seine schrift 17 980
verfasst also praktisch da sind ist die
kritik der reinen vernunft entscheidend
gewesen
die kunden legung meter für sich das ist
nun die zweite bei vorwerk 17 59
natürlich schon die religionen schrift
erschien das erste hauptstück in dem
land sehr viele weitere unterscheidung
eingeführt hat eben auch als als
reaktion auf diese ganze debatte als es
findet vor einem noch erweiterten
problem kontext statt und für vor bergen
ist jetzt gerade kreuzers schrift
überdies kritische betrachtung über die
freiheit des willens zentral
kreuzer hatte in dieser schrift die sehr
provokativ bis geschrieben
nach unseren bisherigen untersuchungen
sind nur zwei wege für uns offen
entweder irgendwie practice muss oder
fatalismus der erste mal eben zu wenigen
mit den gesetzen der theoretischen als
mit den förderungen der praktischen
vereinbaren
der letzte hingegen ist zwar dem ersten
völlig gemäss scheint aber den jetzt
sind durchaus zu widersprechen also bei
kreutzer haben
skeptische betrachtungen die gerade
damit zu tun dass wir uns nicht wirklich
festlegen können wie jetzt freiheit
bestimmt werden soll
wir haben informationen für den in
different ist muss aber eben auch für
den determinismus oder fatalismus und
kreuzwertheim wirklichen dritten weg
zwischen diesen beiden positionen kein
mittelweg und vorwerk möchte jetzt
ebenso wie kann die absicht einen
mittelweg beschreiten zwischen
indifferent ismus und fatalismus oder
beruft sich dabei auch wie habe ich auf
kampf vermissen und möchte die
eigentlich auch noch etwas mehr
rekonstruieren oder eben analysieren wer
die konklusion akzeptieren dass wir ganz
frei gewesen sind er sagt ich meine es
ort neben noch immer der festen
überzeugung dass ich dir eine kantige
freiheitsliebe von dem gefährlichen
klippen des fatalismus und des
individualismus gleich weit entfernt
dass durch sie das wenige problem wie es
allein schon entstanden wäre die
notwendigkeit philosophische
spekulationen der menschen nahe zu legen
ich bloß wie sie dafür halten
seine auflösung näher gebracht sondern
auch bereits vollständig gelöst sein
das ist diese
der bezug zu krank jetzt ist gelöst aber
man kann der noch genauer angeben wie
jetzt die freiheit des willens zu
verstehen ist wie argument vor
argumentiert vorbild dafür dass der
freiwillige stimmt sein muss als er darf
nicht mit indifferenz gleichgesetzt
werden
der freie wille wäre ein grundloses
vermögen wenn er schlechterdings nicht
nach bestimmungen handelte dies wäre dem
sattel des zu reichen kunden zuwider der
als eine regel des denkens nicht weniger
als der satz des widerspruchs über das
ganze gebiet des denkbar seine
herrschaft aus dem leid der freibäder
handelt allerdings nach bestimmung
gefunden
das ist jetzt auch dieses rats
realistische erbe von leibnitz dass auch
eine große rolle spielen der debatte
darf man nicht unterschätzen die
bedeutung von leibnitz also der satz vom
zu reichen kunde der muss einfach
bewahrt werden
der darf nicht aufgegeben werden wenn
wir menschliche willensfreiheit denken
und jetzt argumentiert vor werden im
anschluss an kant für einen
transzendentalen kompatibel ist muss man
denken möchte von freiheit und
bestimmtheit
wir wissen alle dass kant die
bestimmtheit der freiheit vor allem
durch moralische nötigung erreicht und
seien schrift also die bestimmt seit ich
bei nach kant in die freiheit eingeht
ist sie bestimmt durch das sittengesetz
hier hat die die debatte des
integrierten fatalismus entspannen dass
wir dann nicht so leicht erklären können
wie wir uns ebenso aus weit gegen diese
gesetzmäßigkeiten sind im gesetz
entscheiden kann und vorwerk
argumentiert jetzt noch eine stufe
allgemeiner er betrachte ich jetzt nicht
nur die moralische bestimmtheit zu
überhaupt die bestimmtheit der freiheit
als solche und die ist noch wie ein
abstrakter und genereller als die
moralischen bestimmtheit sagen das tönt
es ist toll mit einleuchtend dass die
unvermeidlichkeit einer handlung unter
voraussetzung ihres stimmungs grundes
dich und der freiheit gab wohl nur
einigen lässt also eine art komplett
buddhismus freilich aber nur dann wenn
grund und handlungen nicht in einer zeit
folge gedacht werden
es wäre aber möglich dass die ursachen
finden uns nicht nur jede frei handlung
unter voraussetzungen ihres bundes sind
auch diesem grund unter voraussetzung
eines höheren diese abermals unter
voraussetzung eines noch hören und
sofort als dem vermeintlich zudem auch
diese annahme die wir vor der hand nur
als problematisch auf dem würde die
freiheit keineswegs auch eben zur bald
über diese einzige zugegeben würde das
die ganze vielleicht moment die reifen
und gründen außerhalb dieser zeit drei
ist hier sehen wir das vorher kann es
kredit der reifen und sehr ernst nimmt
mit ihrer neben unterscheidung von
verschiedenen logan zeit logik und
zeitlose logik der auflösung niedriger
als im juni
und das versucht jetzt vorbild fruchtbar
zu machen für die freiheits frage nach
den bestimmungen und wie habe ich
versucht eben vorbei jetzt die
bestimmung gründe genauer zu analysieren
als kann das getan hatte er fragt sich
was sollen wir uns von diesen
bestimmungen gründen eines freien wir
für einen begriff machen werden sie
jetzt nicht nur moralisch gedacht werden
soll
er sagt weiter alle erfahrung an die
form der zeitgewinn ist so können wir so
fruchtbar auch sonstige beat sein mag
gleichwohl nicht hoffen in dem sie eben
auch nur im mindesten spur von
bestimmungen anzutreffen deren
wesentlichstes merkmal darin bestehen
dass in wenigen was durch sie bestimmt
ist durchaus in keiner zeit folge
gedacht werden kann werden sich als über
diese bestimmung spin.de etwas näheres
finden lässt sein werden wir es nirgends
als im gebiete bloße begriffe zu suchen
haben
das ist jetzt ganz interessant weil
jetzt vorwerk die maximen wie ich glaube
auch in anknüpfung an die religion
schrift die maxime neben als diese
gründe anführt die der tod
7 in dem liegt die antwort auf die frage
wie jetzt die die freie
bildungsentscheidung bestimmt ist er
sagt nun lassen sie uns die jenige frei
willens handlung wodurch sich das
subjekt zu hervorbringe einzelner gegen
stimmt eine entschließung jenige aber
durch welchen es sich zu der vorbringen
einer ganzen gattung von gegenständen
bestimmt eine maxime ihnen und sie
werden wir zugeben müssen dass wir in
dem begriff für einer maxi mit den
begriffen eine villensiedlung gefunden
habe welche ihrer natur nach dem grund
anderen sich handlung nämlich der
entschließung gehen sich fast maxime
werden also dasjenige sein was wir auf
zu haben wenn wir nach den gründen
fragen wie die tätigkeit ist verein
bestimmen
ihr benutzt er ganz klar erkannt an und
nehmen die maxime im blick das
entscheidende ist jetzt aber und das
hatte kan zunächst bezieht nicht gesagt
dass diese maxime und individuelle
entscheidung nachdem sie einer zeit
außer zeitlichen logik fallen sich
verhalten wie prämissen das ist dieser
fett gedruckte bereich hier die
prämissen und schluss folge in einer
logischen revolution und die sind
dennoch sagt er kam sah jetzt kann man
sich fragen ob eine detektion eine
logische reaktion auf das etwas
grausames ist es würden sicherlich die
logica bestreiten
aber es hat etwas von einer konsequenz
wenn ich etwas beweisen
dann beweise ich die den schluss nicht
im sinn einer zeitlichen ordnung das
finde ich es recht es ist nicht das ich
dabei eine kausalität vornehmen
aber ich bekomme so eine form von
flüssigkeit oder kohärenz und dass das
ist das worauf jetzt hier
vorwerk abheben dass die maxime und
entschließung nicht in zeit und denkt
sind ungefähr so wie wir uns wissen wann
schluss folge auch in keiner zeit
ordnung und dennoch in einem käufer
fänden vorstellen das finde ich sehr
originell dass sie jetzt hier
die logik oder die mathematik als witz
als referenzrahmen verwendet um die
inneren entschlüsseln weiter zu
analysieren
generell in magazinen und individuelle
entscheidungen folgen einer könnte man
sagen operationalen nur dann sagt sie
nur unsere gedanken folgen der zeit
aufeinander
die logischen gründe und folgen aber die
wir leben können wir uns unmöglich als
veränderung die in der zeit entstehen
und vergehen vorstellungen neben sie die
erstbeste rein mathematische aktion
theoreme und collagen und sagen sie mir
ob die glieder diese reihe ebenso
sukzessiv auseinander entstehen wie die
glieder einer reihe väter kinder und
enkel
das wäre jetzt kausale dialog man sagt
gewiss nicht und was nötig sie also eine
reihe von regeln und hören regeln und
noch höheren regeln die sich der
freiheit selbst vor schreibt gerade in
einer zeit ordnung und nicht vielmehr in
einer bloßen logischen ordnung sich
vorzustellen
also die bestimmung gründe des films die
gehorchen einer bloß logischen ordnung
die nicht mit der zeitlich ordnung von
ursache und wirkung bei einstellen und
deswegen eben auch nicht unseren willen
zu bestimmt dass er dadurch unfreiwillig
sondern diese logische ordnung
ermöglicht gerade die freiheit
natürlich gibt es jetzt hier das problem
dass man immer fragen kann was war doch
maxi mit dieser maxime da bezieht als
ich mir scheint auf die religion stift
kann sprach ja auch von der obersten
maxime der grund- und einsehbar ist
das ist ein intensiver christa hier
droht trotz dieser prinzipiellen
erforderlichkeit des letzten grund dass
der annahme der maxime ist dieser nicht
mehr rational oder des islamistisch
sondern wie jetzt vorbild wie ich finde
das sehr originell seine regulative idee
der vernunft er sagt diese
unvermeidlichkeit nach dem letzten
freie handlung zu fragen verbunden mit
seiner unbegreiflichkeit
charakterisierte ihn als eine regulativ
idee der vernunft dem verstanden das
ziel vorhält dem er sich mit seinen
forschen nach den gründen freier
handlung zu nähern suchen soll
ohne es doch jemals wirklich zu
erreichen
also das ist trotz allem unter vor
schlechten immer noch rational weil es
eine regulative idee der vernunft ist
jetzt was ich kurz zusammen also sowohl
licht als auch versuchen die gründe der
bereich weiter zu bestimmen als kant
getan hat bleiben dabei aber dem
begrifflichen rahmen seiner trans
zentrale philosophie nutzen diese aber
auf eine sehr fruchtbare und originelle
weise wie sowohl habe ich als auf
vorberg versuchen einen dritten weg zu
beschreiten jederzeit indifferent ismus
und fatalismus arbeitet für die freiheit
des willens komplementär zu keinen trans
zentraler reduktion der verstandes
begriffe und vorberg analysiert die
bestimmung des willens durch die
operationale zeitlosigkeit weiter in
analogie zur logischen folge beziehen
ich glaube also dass beide lenker sehr
originell sind und bereits auf diese
größe entwicklung der zu einem deutschen
journalisten haben vorrang weist aber
natürlich immer noch im rahmen dieses
trends im tourismus bleiben und nicht
besteigen wie es eben der versucht der
anderen denke dann war